I'm gonna have some coffee what do you
want some milk
what milk coffee's fine
[Music]
drink it [ __ ] I don't know this is
espresso you know it's like coffee Zilla
is it already Friday again oh hey hey
it's it's Friday which can only mean one
thing late you loose Friday okay what
are we talking about thick first of all
little update on the main channel okay
cuz some people were like oh I haven't
you posted there in a little while and
the reason is cuz after the training to
have video had a video in the works that
had to get cancelled because it just
wasn't the right time for it there were
some sensitive documents involved and I
just felt like it wasn't I just get so I
had to cancel so the next video is
coming out soon it's gonna be out by the
end of the month so don't worry coffee
this channel has not in any way taken
away from coffee break this is where I
come when I'm just like I'm tired of the
you know high production value feeling
like an idea isn't good enough for
coffee break so this is really more like
R&R for me and I hope you guys enjoyed -
I know you like the series so without
further ado we're gonna get into Dona
leprae probably the guy the best case
study for why you should not drop [ __ ] I
don't appraise of found out about drop
shipping before it was cool
he's the tiny classified ad guy have you
seen this guy the second way to make
money that I stumbled onto was placing
time
by the ads in the newspaper if you
create and test one time to classify
that in the newspaper that makes just
thirty to forty dollars profit in a week
it could make you a fortune because the
secret is learning how to take that one
tiny classified ad that just made thirty
to forty dollars profit in a week and to
realize that you could now take that
same exact ad and place it in up to
three thousand other newspapers around
the country that's what I did I found
tiny class okay I know tiny question do
you guys get the point
Donna pray was a pitchman from I think
I'm pretty sure was a 90s and he his big
thing with the tiny classified ads which
he repeats about ten thousand times in
this video but what was the tiny
classified ad idea well basically you
could advertise in newspapers I was like
that one of the big ways you advertise
back then and Donna and pray said well
look you can create an ad that like
basically sells some info product or
some kind of product that maybe you
don't even own and then you get an order
form from all the people who ride in or
call in and then you go out and you sell
it for more than it's worth and then you
purchased it from those people and
you're sort of the middleman
you've like fulfill the request now does
that sound like anything that is pitched
today as a fake guru idea if you give me
45 seconds I'm gonna show you how my
buddy Justin generates nearly five
hundred thousand dollars per month
selling weird stuff like cat socks
fishing t-shirts and of course the
legendary wolf mug of truth and justice
it's actually quite simple all he does
is create ecommerce dropshipping sores
and then target people on and then sell
some things they're interested in I was
able to go from zero to one point five
million dollars drop shipping on Shopify
within twelve months but for you to
understand my story we need to transport
our way to the Shopify back-office which
we could do right here so what we're
looking at is the
classified-ad that just made 30 to 40
dollars profit in a week and to realize
Don leprae is the father of online
dropshipping apparently so what's what's
fascinating to me about this is that a
Don leprae was literally charged with 41
counts of conspiracy mail fraud wire
fraud promotional money laundering
transactional money money laundering
criminal forfeiture I mean he who it's
got is busted for for ripping off
customers and ultimately we should we
found out that the people who were
responding to his tiny classified ads
weren't actually making all that much
money shocker now I want to say this
right up front okay I'm not against drop
shipping per se which is just the
concept that you take some niche product
from a whole seller you go and advertise
it you find a customer and then you
connect these two and then the whole
seller sends it to the customer the
customer pays you and then you basically
take the take the profits okay so that's
that's basically how dropshipping works
in a nutshell I'm not against it in
principle in principle it can make some
money the problem is is people like
Donna pray who's running is classified
ad scam people people like like Mike
Vestal running courses people like Alex
Becker running courses the problem is
they make it sound so easy they make it
sound like you're only you're not only a
click away from making millions on
Shopify and there have been a ton of
reports of people faking their Shopify
account stores all this kind of stuff
and why would someone do that well
because if you can make it seem like
it's really easy to make money on
Shopify people see you as a guru then
they go to you and they pay for your you
know 500 $1000 $10,000 course so so
again I'm not against drop shipping per
se I think it's a really hard business I
think there are a lot easier businesses
I think it's really saturated right now
I think the idea of niche products being
so findable is ridiculous but is it
technically a way to make money yeah
I've known people who've made a small
amount of money you're not gonna become
rich on it
in all likelihood but you know I just I
had to say I don't think drop shipping
is a scam but I do find it funny that
Donna Bray was he found in drop shipping
all your fake gurus they really are like
oh their livelihood to all Don and you
know what there's something about Don
that I sort of I sort of like you know
like there's something kind of likable
about him yeah I don't know what it
maybe it's the fact that he's standing
he doesn't have the stupid you know
Tesla Ferrari behind him he's you know
he's sitting next to a beach egg and
kind of I kind of like that although the
beach is roaring during this thing I
don't know if you guys noticed that this
isn't this my dad's that made 30 to 40
dollars profit in a way Oh
the South the yoke but I don't know
maybe it's just nostalgia he's kind of
lovable
but really but really he's the founder
looking you wanted all your guys all
your fake gurus think they're great this
guy did it all and then eventually of
course he died right before going to
prison but that's another story for
another day
now the last thing I wanna talk about
with Don Lecrae besides him being your
favorite gurus basically forefather I
want to talk about the greatest vitamin
in the world all right so the greatest
vitamin in the world is the thing that
don don spun off into after his his tiny
classified ads wasn't working all that
well he tried a few other things too but
the greatest item in the world is a just
some ripoff formula the FDA later said
it didn't do anything Don leprae said it
cured of course he did he's a cure
diabetes cancer arthritis yeah um
probably the greatest fighter in the
world it cures it
do you have generalized anxiety you know
but the real genius behind the greatest
vitamin in the world was his selling
system which I can't believe people fell
for this okay check this out get twenty
new people to agree to try these
vitamins and I get paid a thousand
dollars yes and the best part is you
don't have to do any selling you just
send people to your website and the
website educates the people it takes the
order and it does everything for you
oh wait does this remind you of anything
else you know everybody says how much
money they're making blah blah $6,000
essentially it's a pyramid
scheme you get people to you know try
the product underneath you it's like an
MLM you get people to try products
underneath you and if you get people to
try it 20 products you get paid a
thousand dollars and you could have
you're an independent advertiser and
then you get your independent advertiser
underneath you who's also selling and
you make money on what they do but what
what was unique about Donald praise
approach is Don didn't graduate high
school now what does that mean well it
means he's not too good at math so he
said that you could you'd get a thousand
dollars if you sold twenty products 20
got twenty people to try one product
okay well how much does a product cost
well a product retail a greatest vitamin
in the world retails for $45 so if you
get 20 people
Donna pray
brings in $900 this is before he pays
for the bottle before he pays for
anything else and then he's supposed to
give you a thousand dollars this is
totally unrelated to all the bonuses and
stuff he included he put out all the
stuff he said you're gonna thousand
those you're gonna know you're getting a
thousand dollars and meanwhile he's only
making nine hundred dollars when you're
supposed to be getting a thousand
dollars so what ends up happening well
mister can't do math ends up getting
busted on this and this is this was
actually the big thing he got busted on
the tiny classified ads he got in
trouble for but he wasn't ever like
completely thrown into prison for the
greatest item in the world is what he
really got destroyed on and yeah because
you can't not pay people and he wasn't
paying people because you can't pay a
thousand dollars when you make $900 so
that is the story a bond leprae but what
can we learn from him well we can learn
a few things number one your drop
shipping gurus they ain't original
you're not even original for being
scammed by it people have been being
scammed by you know looks easy drop
shipping scams pay for my info product
for years so that's number one number
two we also know the life cycle of the
Guru starting starting out the Guru
makes wild claims Donna Price said he
was making fifty thousand dollars a week
doing his tiny classified ads he gets a
little notoriety his products are
staying off he actually becomes wealthy
because he sold so many of these bogus
products and
he's that kind of Peters out then he
starts the greatest item in the world
people start to know him as a scam and
then and then you tip and you end up
getting caught so the reason I talk
about people like Don leprae and the
reason that I talked about like the
lifecycle of fake gurus is that a lot of
people see new fake gurus come on the
scene and they're like oh well I'm not
seeing anything sketchy yet so I should
just believe this person know I'm Brock
Johnson I went from zero to six million
dollars in my first six months I on
Amazon and on August first ever seen a
horse or something like that before if
it looks like a Donna pray if it talks
like a dong leprae if it walks like a
Donna leprae it's probably a tiny
classified ad
[Music]
but never to the trust